[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and when this video
gets out we're gonna let there be
carnage
now the trailer for venom two has just
dropped and it's so good
eminem is about to make the best rap
song of all time about it
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the ins and outs of the
first look
pointing out some of the easter eggs
things you missed and our general
reaction to the trailer
there may be some spoilers here so if
you like to go into movies as blind as
possible then i highly suggest that you
turn off now
don't forget to hit the thumbs up button
if you enjoy it and make sure you
subscribe to the channel to never miss a
video
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown
of venom let there be carnage the
trailer
now the trailer itself opens in san
francisco which was of course the same
place that the first movie was set
we can see eddie and venom are pretty
much in an odd couple situation
and the latter sings the song let's call
the whole thing off which
first appeared in the 1937 film shall we
dance
this was about two people who would
pretty much disagree on their
pronunciation of words like tomato
tomato potato potato and initially the
song was about refined accents
over time though it's come to be used in
pop culture films like when harry met
sally
to pretty much show two opposites having
to try and work together
until they end up putting heads over it
we also see there is one rule which is
no eating people
something that brock established at the
end of the prior movie
venom is clearly sticking to this as he
makes some waffles that
look like the kind of thing i'd knock up
the one time my wife asks me to make
breakfast
make it yourself you [ __ ] now we then
cut to him visiting mrs
chen the convenience store owner from
the first film who venom of course saved
when eddie walks past you can actually
see a cameo by stan lee
as his face is on a magazine cover now
we sort of play upon the prior movie
quite a bit as
in the next clip we see that eddie has
still been visiting cletus cassidy in
jail
which of course ties into the
post-credits scene of that film we can
hear cassidy's voice narrating the clip
and he does the old speech you know the
one the one that villains always do
you and me we're not so different that
one that one you know that one
now we can see that the character has
had his hair cut and though it's not as
ridiculous as the sideshow bob one from
last time
it's it's still pretty bad it's still
pretty bad
now in his cell he's carved childlike
drawings into the walls
these include teddy bears and a tree in
a later shot
clearly they link back to his childhood
and in the first look we see brock going
through some similar drawings
according to leaks on the film cassidy
has several victims that have not been
discovered
that eddie is trying to find the remains
of this will of course
bring closure to the families and mean
that they finally know what happened to
their relatives
whilst we can never fully verify leaks
like this until the film is out
i think this is probably true as we see
a police officer in the next scene
being played by steven graham reading a
paper on this the headline says
the hidden victims of cletus cassidy
further tying back to this leak
now when the policeman closes the
newspaper we can also see a headline
that mentions an adventure
i can't quite make out exactly what this
says but it does look like it says
avengers leave nightmare
perhaps hinting towards one division now
on his newspaper
and eddie's laptop we can see a daily
bugle from paige
this is using the same logo and colours
as the raimi verse
perhaps linking into that though it
might just be
a graphic designer got lazy one day
unfortunately i can't quite make out the
headline
due to the reflection in the shot but it
does say mind on it this could be
delving into cletus's mind
i think that eddie brock in this scene
is very much going over the evidence
now what i love about this is just how
dark they're going with it
cassidy in the comics was always a
deeply disturbed individual
and a complete homicidal maniac that
took pleasure in causing death
as a child cassidy some of the most
serial killers
tortured several animals before moving
on to people
it's suspected that his mental health
conditions were caused by his father
who brutally beat his mother in front of
him whatever the case
cletus had a very messed up childhood
that led him further down a dark path
he ended up killing his grandmother by
pushing her down a flight of steps
and also tried to kill his mother by
electrocuting her
this was done by throwing a hairdryer
into her bath and
naturally she didn't take it too well
she she tried to kill cassidy who
managed to overpower her
and then cletus's father took the fall
though we all know who it really was
either way he was sent to the saint
esther's home for boys which was an
orphanage
here he was mocked by the staff and
children because of his anti-social
behavior
he pushed a girl who rejected him in
front of a bus and
ended up burning down the orphanage so
all round nice guy
and definitely someone that you really
want to be friends with now cletus is
clearly living his last days and
in the trailer we see the preparation
for his execution being put into place
however it backfires and he manages to
escape because carnage takes over
we do know that there existed several
versions of the symbiote
but how they explain him getting one i
have no idea
potentially the prison right we see
leads to venom breaking it up
and during the chaos some of him might
get on cassidy but let me know
your theories below i'll cut to a shot
of anne played by michelle williams
meeting eddie in a restaurant i just
hope they don't serve lobster hey
having that now we we then go to
ravencroft
which in the marvel universe is an
institute for the criminally insane
this is pretty much your orcam asylum in
marvel comics
i think that cletus will burst several
villains out of this including one
we see close up here this is shriek the
girlfriend of cassidy
who becomes a big villain in the maximum
carnage story
shriek is played by naomi harris of
james bond fame and has a marking around
her eye
that is clearly playing on the comic
version of the character we can catch
her in a cell at one point
while shrieking so yeah i'm not the only
one who does crap buns
and they are clearly playing it very
close to the source material
in the first film we saw as several
homeless people were experimented on
so it's even possible that similar
things were done to the prisoners
which is how she can do this when the
gods and orderlies go to visit her in
her cell
they have big earmuffs covering their
heads so
maybe she has always had this ability in
the film universe
now there's also a spider which gets
crushed by cletus
whilst he talks about a rescuer who
never comes clearly this is a reference
to spider-man
and if this movie is linked in with the
mcu
then peter obviously has his own
problems to worry about right now
now it's not too long before we get our
first look at carnage
and he looks incredible they really
captured the look of the comics
and managed to magnify the horrifying
aspects of him
he smashes helicopters and cars and
generally
just looks great now he also manifests
several weapons
which was a big thing that he and the
symbiotes in general are capable of
we then see the rest of the scene from
the convenience store and this is a call
back to the first venom trailer which
ended in a similar way
however that's not all and our final
shot is of carnage in a church
why this is important is because in
general symbiotes are weak to sonic's
most notably church bells throughout the
comics churches have been used as key
locations to bring them down
and at one point in the trailer we do
see venom travelling to on
i think that this will be where the
final battle is held at and it will be
how brock manages to take carnage down
by using sound as a weapon however
carnage also has shriek on his side
so it will be interesting to see how she
is utilized as she could provide a big
obstacle for him
either way it's a brilliant finish to
this trailer and it shows the big bad
off in all his glory
now before we get into our reaction i'd
obviously love to hear your thoughts on
the trailer so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the trailer
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
okay so as for the trailer itself i have
to say
i really enjoyed it i don't know what it
is with sony trailers but
this one and the previous one for mobius
both had
a really shadowy aspect to them that
makes it feel like the studio are
leaning into the darker side of these
characters
we don't have a rating for it just yet
but there are rumors that sony are going
to be going for an
r however i don't really think that this
will be the case
as they still want to sell tickets with
the company now being tied heavily into
marvel studios
it does make sense that they would try
and align themselves more with that
universe
and though i would love to see an r8
venom film i highly doubt we're going to
be getting it
you have to remember that the first
movie was meant to be rated r as well
and we all saw how that turned out now
alrighty comic book movies can be
successful
so who knows time will tell and with a
storyline about a serial killer
this definitely feels like they should
be going all out with it we have to tell
cletus's origin
story and set him up as a true threat so
i do think that that would not only be
true to the original source material
but also it's something that fans really
want to see i just hope that the studio
don't put profits solely before the
vision of the director
as r-rated movies can be successful and
it just feels like the direction
that they should be going in it's
difficult to tell exactly how the film
will be from this first look
but as someone that actually liked the
original movie i am quite hyped for what
we have in store
there's so many other avenues they can
explore with this spider-verse whether
they decide to link it in with the
bigger storyline of the work or not
and i am kind of hoping that sony used
these characters to guard on avenues
that the studio heads at marvel would be
afraid to
why i'm excited after seeing this is
because it does indeed look like that is
the route that they're traversing
and there are a ton of things in this
trailer that have me extremely excited
for the movie
at this rate it's going to be one of the
biggest comic book films of 2021 which
though it isn't hard here does show that
sony have the potential to really sweep
the board with their properties
overall this has got me really excited
for the movie and i can't wait to see
what it's like when it releases later
this year
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer and if there's anything
we missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the shangchi trailer which
will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over everything you need to
know about the characters in it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
have any questions over the film
without the way i've been paul you've
been the best and i'll see you next time
take care peace